Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and yesterday
in my Suicide Squad video I asked you to submit
all your questions.
I picked 10 of them to answer in this video
with one bonus question.
So much to talk about Harley Quinn, the finale,
season 3.
The throughline in the episode and something
I think will play into the finale is that
line, “A Bad Man Turned Good.”
Just remember that idea when you think about
the big villains this season.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Arrow and Flash videos every week with
bonus Q&As.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions for future videos you
want me to do.
So let’s answer some questions.
Careful for spoilers if you’re not caught
up on the show.
Question 1 - Z Music 2013 asks Do you think
Shrapnel blowing up is like a grundy thing?
Where they end up returning looking more like
they do in the comics?
Mark Guggenheim explained that they chose
to kill Shrapnel just because they wanted
to convey the idea that the Suicide Squad
members are expendable.
That doesn’t mean he couldn’t come back
in a future episode.
But we’re supposed to think he’s dead.
Don’t plan on seeing him again the rest
of this season, but until you see someone’s
cold body on a table.
They’re not confirmed dead.
And if they ever introduce weirder powers
on the show like Magic or the lazarus pit,
death will become meaningless.
Which is part of the reason they haven’t
done that yet.
But I’m really hoping to see someone literally
come back from the dead soon.
Agent Coulson style.
Question 2 - BD Destro asks Do you think Deathstroke
and Merlyn are working together?
No, I think Merlin’s involvement is purely
tied to Thea and Moira.
If there’s any Slade crossover it will be
coincidental.
Merlin is such a big character though, I would
be really disappointed if he doesn’t fight
Slade at some point.
Merlin wants to protect Thea, Slade wants
to destroy Oliver’s family.
It only stands to reason that at some point,
Merlin will end up fighting Slade with Oliver
or helping Oliver in some way.
Remember the theme of the Suicide Squad episode.
A Bad man turned good.
I think that’s foreshadowing for both Merlin
and Slade this season.
Question 3 - DigiDestined 5555 asks Do you
think that Slade could be Roy's father, and
that's why he survived the serum?﻿
I think that’s an awesome theory, here’s
what is said about Roy’s Father in the comic
books.
His history has been retconned a few times,
but for a while he was a wealthy businessman
who died in a plane crash on on an island,
leaving Roy stranded.
Kind of like Oliver’s father died in the
boat crash leaving him stranded.
Another time Roy’s father was a scientist
who died when one of his experiments exploded.
Like Doctor Ivo (even though Ivo isn’t confirmed
dead yet).
So you can tie Roy to characters that already
exist on the show.
But I think those are just coincidences.
I think that Roy survived just because he’s
special like Slade and Oliver.
I think Oliver would totally have survived
the mirakuru if Ivo had dosed him with it.
But it is fun to think about Arrow as having
this Empire Strikes Back storyline.
Deathstroke is Darth Vader with the mask and
he tries to turn Roy to the darkside by revealing
he can give him what he wants more than Oliver
can.
I just like the idea of that Deathstroke Empire
Strikes Back.
That would make a great spinoff show.
Question 4 - Lunatic Reason (no avatar) asks
They mentioned Markovia again.
Anyone want to see the Outsiders like I do?
They should do a season with Green Arrow travelling
the world on the hunt or Slade.
Rex Mason in Egypt, Katana in Japan, Geo Force
in Markovia and so on.
Nice idea, as Arrow progresses into Season
3 and beyond I definitely think we’ll see
the show tell more international stories.
The Universe is always expanding.
Just ask Neil Degrasse Tyson and Carl Sagan.
Most of the time they don’t do stories like
that just because they have to focus on building
Starling City stories, which this season is
the Deathstroke A-story.
Smaller plots like the suicide squad have
to bow in service of that at a certain point.
So they can’t just jump from superhero to
superhero all over the place.
But next season you’ll definitely see even
more suicide squad, more travel and more new
secondary characters.
A lot of those new characters will probably
be shared with The Flash, also in service
of creating this unified universe just like
Marvel is doing with their movies and tv shows.
Question 5 - Thomas McCain asks in the last
scene with Sara and Oliver in the episode,
when Oliver takes Sara's hand, did anyone
else get the expectation that one of them
were going to propose?
Nice theory, in case anyone hasn’t read
the comics.
There was a certain point several years ago
where Green Arrow and Black Canary got married.
The show has been shipping them hard this
season and I’ve seen a lot of evidence to
suggest Caity Lotz will be back next season,
but there hasn’t been any confirmation.
So Deathstroke could still kill her.
I’m hoping he just kills Moira, not that
I hate her.
It’s just that I love Caity Lotz so much.
And someone has to die.
If the Canary survives through the finale,
them doing the marriage storyline would be
an awesome cliffhanger for Season 3 and give
Oliver’s character an interesting place
to go emotionally.
Remember how he said to Felicity that he has
to keep everyone at arm’s length just to
protect them.
What would happen if he ever got married to
someone.
Sara said she’s not the girl on the island
anymore, so it’s possible that they want
us to think that she’s strong enough as
a character to withstand being in a long term
intimate relationship with Oliver.
Being married to a superhero isn’t all fun
and games.
There’s a lot of punching and kicking.
Question 6 - Roque Yanez asks Who would be
your picks for a Teen Titan’s spinoff?
Off the top of my head i’d say you have
to do Cyborg, Ravager, Jericho and Roy.
I don’t know how they’d do beast boy,
starfire or raven at this point, just because
we haven’t seen those types of powers on
the show yet.
And Superboy is a whole messy copyright issue.
I think in season 3 what we’ll see is a
mini-teen titans esque story.
Like Roy and Sin and a couple other characters
will get a side story that Oliver isn’t
a part of.
That will be the closest thing to a live action
Teen Titans.
If it goes well they’ll totally develop
it for pilot someday.
Question 7 - Jim Moriarty asks How do you
think the Suicide Squad will be a part of
the final fight with Deathstroke?
Yes, that’s what that whole finale scene
with Amanda Waller was.
They’re going to use them whenever Oliver
finally goes after Slade.
Episode 18 is called Deathstroke, so it could
either come then or in one of the final episodes.
Shrapnel is dead for all intents and purposes.
So either it will just be Bronze Tiger, Deadshot,
Diggle and Lyla.
Or they’ll add another villain, like Merlyn
or Huntress.
I’m not expecting any other new comic characters
outside of Ra’s Al Ghul, and the two Flash
people Killer Frost and Vibe.
I don’t any of them will join the Squad.
The interesting thing is that I don’t think
this final fight, will be the final fight.
I think Ra’s Al Ghul will come and Slade
will end up having to work with Oliver temporarily.
I don’t think he’ll stop being a bad guy,
but it will be like Deadshot.
They’re still self-serving villains, but
they just team up with heroes breifly.
And in this case Slade and Oliver will have
to work together to deal with Ra’s Al Ghul
after he comes.
At least if Manu Bennett’s comments on the
arrival of Ra’s Al Ghul are to be believed.
We’ll have to see how it actually goes down.
But remember that big theme.
A Bad Man Turned Good.
Question 8 - Jose Beltran asks do you think
Barry Allen will be present for the fight
with Slade?
No, Marc Guggenheim actually confirmed that
in this timeline of events, Barry is still
in the coma.
He’ll wake up in the Pilot episode of The
Flash.
So that’s why those other Flash characters
are cameoing in episode 20.
No idea what they’ll be doing in Starling
City though.
Question 9 - HG Drifter asks Do you think
we'll get the actual Oracle or will Felicity
fill her role in the Birds of Prey episode?﻿
Felicity will fill the role of Oracle, because
her character is wheelchair bound we’re
all kind of worried for her safety.
I think Arrow will just change things a little,
so she can become that Oracle character without
getting her spine broken.
Just like the suicide squad, they’re going
to be slowly developing the Birds of Prey
as a thing on Arrow though.
So there will be more Huntress, Canary, Felicity
team ups in season 3.
Think of next week’s episode as like the
beginning of that.
They won’t be best friends at the beginning
though.
Their trio relationship will evolve over time.
Question 10 - 101 Movie Games (no avatar)
asks Episode 19 is called Under the Hood do
you think this could mean Red Hood or just
play on words?
It means a couple things, but it has nothing
to do with The Red Hood.
First it’s a reference to someone else finding
out Oliver’s true identity.
Probably Detective Lance or Laurel.
Only one person is going to learn who he is.
The second meaning is Roy, his Arsenal/Red
Arrow persona will be developing more.
The episode after that is called Seeing Red,
so I think that will mostly continue the Roy-Red
Arrow plot.
He’s supposed to get his official costume
this season.
So that might be when that happens.
Bonus question - LA Prodigy asks Do you think
that the Arrow/Flash Universe will ever be
a part of the Batman/Superman Movie universe?
I think they’re definitely trying to make
that happen as much as possible.
Warner Brothers did have Christopher Nolan
overseeing their DC Comics Properties like
Joss Whedon is doing for Marvel.
If you’re not familiar, Joss Whedon isn’t
just directing the Avengers movies, he’s
like the creative director for the Marvel
Universe.
That means he steps in to all of their movies
and shows and talks with the writers and directors
to make sure everything blends with everything
else they’re trying to do.
I don’t think Christopher Nolan is doing
that for DC and Warner Brothers anymore, but
if he’s not, then someone else is.
I know Geoff Johns is highly involved with
the creative aspects of all their tv shows
in development.
So short answer yes, they are all connected.
Asterisk though, not as connected as Marvel’s
Universe.
So thank you so much guys for submitting you’re
questions.
These types of videos are always fun to do.
Next week is birds of prey.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video.
I’ve got a bunch of other videos to do,
but I’ll try to do another bonus Flash video
soon.
Right now click here for my suicide squad
review and click here to learn more about
the flash.
Thanks for watching.
See you guys tonight.
High Fives!